good morning john in the year 2000 juan
and pedro sanchez two brothers in mexico
were drilling down in a mine that like a
lead in silver mine it was hot down
there like 130 degrees fahrenheit it was
i imagine unpleasant and dangerous work
and mines are always contending with a
lot of different hazards one of them
though is water because mines are
underground and water goes down people
and equipment both work best when they
are not submerged in 130 degree water so
mines almost always have huge pumps that
remove a tremendous amount of water from
the ground so that people and machines
can work down there well in this mine in
mexico something magnificent had been
uncovered by those pumps with that water
taken out those brothers drilled down
into a giant cave full of some of the
largest crystals ever discovered on
earth now an important thing to know you
cannot go visit these crystals one
because the mine has since stopped
pumping the water out and so that cavern
is now full of water again but maybe
more importantly the scientists who did
get a chance to go down into this cave
they had to wear some very special suits
and those suits were designed to do two
things one keep them cool because not
only is it 130 degrees fahrenheit that's
55 celsius it was also extremely humid
because like there's a lot of water down
there and all that water was evaporating
into that very hot air and so it was
like 90 to 99 humidity in there which
meant that the water that you sweat
can't evaporate from your skin into the
air there's no room left in the air for
more water so you have no system for
cooling yourself off and you would
overheat and die and more terrifyingly
they also had to wear basically scuba
equipment they had to breathe air that
they carried around with them but why
because the air down there isn't
poisonous there's not like some weird
alien spores that are going to infect
their lungs it turns out that 130 degree
air can hold a lot of water right so 100
humidity with 130 degree air that's a
lot of water in the air and when you
bring the temperature of air down it can
hold less water so that water condenses
out that's why lots of water vapor going
up into the atmosphere condenses into
clouds when it reaches higher colder
areas of the atmosphere yes that's where
clouds come from also why a glass a cold
iced tea has water conducting on the
side of it because the the air hits the
side of that glass cools down and the
water falls out when it's 130 degrees
and 100 humidity outside you know what's
cooler than the air
the inside of your lungs so if you
didn't have a tank of air on your back
every breath you would take in this cave
would condense a little bit more water
in your lungs a little more a little
more until you drown now this did not
happen to anyone they knew that it was a
thing and so they were able to plan
around it but still
that's why this
is a really really really cool planet
but in a sense like we kind of never
should have seen that cave and now
that the mine is no longer pumping the
water out we can't see it anymore it's
just down there and we had this very
narrow slice of like five years during
which we could examine and study these
giant crystals we only got to see those
crystals because of a truly bizarre
series of coincidences this reminds me
of how in rome they've spent 40 years
trying to build a single subway line but
every time they dig they find some other
like truly irreplaceable remarkable
archaeological site there's just so much
that remains hidden from us i told
katherine about these crystal caves and
she like exclaimed on our walk home the
earth is an alien planet which is just
such a good line because of course like
there is nothing less alien than the
planet that we evolved to exist on that
we as a species have barely ever left
that sustains us every day but also
it is right even after all of this
inquiry it remains full of the unknown
and it's so inhospitable to us in
everywhere except the very narrow slice
just at the surface and yet as we
continue to prove over and over again
these unknowns
are knowable and i know that this
doesn't make any like philosophical
sense but making those unknowns known
whether they are about avocados and
megafauna or giant crystal caves it just
seems like a very good use of time john
i'll see you on tuesday